This question, reading about generic oxygen therapy, I'm surprised to find a little to
know, little to support it as effective on its own against cancer. There are studies showing
effectiveness in conjunction with chemotherapy and radiation, lowering cancer resistance,
cells resistance, but studies that show hyperbaric oxygen therapy, that's H-bot, hyperbaric oxygen
therapy, that's you're in a hyperbaric oxygen chamber, that's what this person's talking about,
about oxygen therapy. So hyperbaric oxygen therapy effectiveness on its own don't seem to exist
is this what you have found also. So, you know, I've also said this before, it's hard to get
a study approved unless you're combining it with chemotherapy or radiation. So if you're going
to combine, you know, if you're going to do a study on curcumin as a beneficial nutrient for
cancer patients, most a lot of the studies that you're going to Google and find out there are studies
that are saying people who are on chemotherapy and doing curcumin are do do better than people
that are on chemotherapy are not doing curcumin. Well, what about those who are doing chemotherapy?
Well, they couldn't get approval for their study and they can't get study dollars money
to run a study unless it's tied with chemotherapy or radiation. That's just the financial situation
with trying to get the national institutes of health to authorize a study and to get funding,
government to fund because mostly studies that are done on cancer are done with governmental
grants or they're funded by the drug company itself. So, what's the benefit of a drug company
who sells chemotherapy to fund a study using HBOT with chemotherapy? Well, the reason is that
they realize that there's a large percentage of people that are going to use curcumin and
green tea extract and verborid and HBOT and things. So, they might as well cash hit on that and
they do it they do a study that is done with chemotherapy and radiation. They're by giving evidence
that and giving information to the general public that you of course everybody does chemotherapy
and radiation. So, it's kind of a mind game that they play with people too. So, it is difficult
to find research and I've said this multiple times before that unless you couple research with
chemotherapy and radiation, meaning unless you couple research with current standards of care,
it's going to be difficult to get a study approved and number two, it's going to be difficult to get
funding to do a study. It's very expensive to do a study. People have asked why are there more
studies on RIF technology because there's no money in it and to get a study approved for something
that costs a lot of money and they're not going to approve a study on doing RIF therapy versus
doing chemotherapy or they're not going to approve a study doing HBOT versus doing chemotherapy
or curcumin versus chemotherapy. They're never going to approve that study. It's never going to
be approved. Why? Because the drug companies control the national interests of health. You'll never get
approval to do a study like that because quite honestly they'd be afraid of the outcome.
So, and then secondly, you won't get funding. So, you just kind of have to understand that.